une plate forme de revendications d'une
cinquantaine de points datant de 2018
pourtant presque deux ans après force
est de constater que la problématique
lors des connes reste entière et les
solutions mises en place trop peu
nombreuses dans la salle syndicats
associations écologiques féministe et
organisations agricoles des agriculteurs
qui réclament toujours une cartographie
précise des terres polluées et la
récupération des terres en friche entre
le peuple on plante on nourrir le peuple
encore contrôler une nutrition face un
problème sanitaire de grande ampleur et
aujourd'hui nous apprenons les
politiques apprennent les
responsabilités pour lesquels ils ont
été élus il ya dix-neuf mille hectares
de friches de terrain en friche en
martinique
donc c'est presqu'autant que la surface
agricole utilisée et le disons que il
est aujourd'hui plus que temps que les
responsables politiques prennent leurs
responsabilités pour activer les pour
nous aider à nous accompagnait a activé
les procédures le lyonnaise qui
souhaitent placer la question du
chlordécone au coeur de la campagne
électorale en adressant une lettre
ouverte au maire et en interpellant des
candidats aux municipales en cette
période électorale
nous demandons au maire de se
positionner fermement sur la question de
la traçabilité des aliments donner à nos
enfants car aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
circuit contrôlé c'est sécurisé sur les
légumes les fruits qui sont données à
nos enfants dans les cantines et après
30 ans est un principe de précaution
qu'il faut absolument appliquer pour nos
enfants sachant que la chlordécone est
un perturbateur endocrinien des
militants qui demande aussi des
engagements plus fermes de l'état et la
généralisation de moyens de lutte contre
la contamination des terres et de la
population identifiées et validées par
les autorités